less than a day after armed robbery
suspect dante wright was shot by police
the name of the police officer who who
pulled the trigger was publicly released
shortly after that
her address was leaked as well now her
home is currently surrounded by concrete
barricades
metal fencing and armed police guards in
order to stop the violent mob from
burning it to the ground and perhaps
killing anyone who happens to be inside
the house
this is the way it goes with every
high-profile police shooting the name of
the police officer is quickly released
soon all of their other personal details
follow and then oftentimes as happened
with the officer in this case they're
charged with a crime
well i shouldn't say that it works this
way with every high profile police
shooting there is
one quite notable exception it was
announced yesterday by the doj that the
officer who shot ashley babbitt one of
the pro-trump protesters at the capitol
on january 6th
will not be charged in her death the
statement from the doj refers to this
man
only as the u.s capitol police officer
because his name was never made public
we don't know his name four months later
and we know absolutely nothing
about the federal officer who shot an
unarmed woman in the capital
compare that to nearly any police
shooting that blm gets upset about where
we're told nearly every personal detail
about the officer within hours of the
shooting
before we even consider the specific
details of the shooting which we will
which left ashley babbitt dead what few
details we have as officials refuse to
tell us much of anything really
it's already unthinkable and outrageous
that this dichotomy exists
there are two systems in this country
two tiers of justice one for the
politically favored
one for the rest of us if you're shocked
by police and blm appoints you a martyr
for their cause
the name of the officer will be made
public he'll likely be charged with a
crime unless the shooting was so
incontrovertibly above board that
prosecutors can't come up with a crime
that would theoretically cover it
meanwhile protesters will wreak havoc in
the streets and be allowed to do it
and the media will canonize you okay
that's how it goes in that case
but if you're shot by police and blm
decides that your death doesn't matter
or even that you deserved what you got
then the officer's name will never be
given to the public the media will
quickly move on from the story
the protesters will sit on their hands
and the officer will be quickly cleared
of all wrongdoing
without any real explanation either
whatever you think of the ashley babbitt
shooting whether you believe it to be
justified or not and i'm not sure how
you could be sure that it is justified
given that the powers that be haven't
even bothered to justify it
but whatever the case may be for you you
should not be okay
with this state of affairs that you
should at least
agree that we should know the officer's
name just as we know the names of the
officers in every other high-profile
incident
this is not merely about being fair or
having the same standard for everyone
though it is partially about that
it's also about understanding the true
motivations of the police officer who
fired the shot
this was obviously a politically charged
situation
most of the rioters and protesters were
right-wing trump supporters
many officers were there that day not
one of them
saved this one felt that it was
necessary to start shooting
is it possible that this officer had
ideological and political conflicts of
interest
that he was pushed to take a step that
no other officer took due to his
political hatred for the people there
i have no idea that's the point none of
us know
could be couldn't be these are the kinds
of questions we should ask these are the
kinds of questions the government would
answer
if we truly lived in a free country
where everybody is equal under the law
now it's possible that this man who shot
her as an honest and straightforward
guy as honest as they come his motives
as pure as the driven snow but
they aren't giving us any information
about him and so we're left only to
speculate
about what his motivations might be
here's what we are being told and this
is about the sum of it really
from the doj statement yesterday i'll
read it to you not the whole thing but
this is the relevant portion
it says the focus of the criminal
investigation was to determine whether
federal prosecutors
could prove that the officer violated
any federal laws
in order to establish a violation of
this statute prosecutors must prove
beyond a reasonable doubt
that the officer acted willfully to
deprive ms babbitt of a right protected
by the constitution or
other law um the hear the fourth
amendment right not to be subjected to
an unreasonable seizure
prosecutors would have to prove not only
that the officer used force that was
constitutionally unreasonable
but the officer did so willfully which
the supreme court has interpreted to
mean that the officer acted with a bad
purpose to disregard the law
as this requirement has been interpreted
by the courts evidence that an officer
acted out of fear mistake panic
misperception negligence or even poor
judgment cannot establish the high level
of intent required under section 242
the investigation revealed no evidence
to establish beyond a reasonable doubt
that the officer willfully committed a
violation
specifically the investigation revealed
no evidence to establish that at the
time of the officer
fired a single shot at miss babbitt the
officer did not reasonably believe that
it was necessary to do so in
self-defense or in defense of the
members of congress and others
evacuating the house chamber
acknowledging the tragic loss of life
and offering condolences to miss
babbitt's family the u.s attorney's
office and u.s department of justice
have therefore closed the investigation
into this matter and that's it
that's the end of it as far as they're
concerned
the the people who've been screaming
about police brutality for years
and accusing cops of being homicidal
lunatics are also perfectly satisfied
with that
in this one case they're satisfied with
that in this one specific case
they're suddenly okay with an unarmed
woman being shot
without any given ex did you notice that
they don't actually tell us why he did
it
they give a a range of possible reasons
and don't tell us what the reason was
they say well it could have been out of
fear it could even be out of negligence
it could have been because he feared
yeah who knows well which is it
what did he say was his reason
we have zero transparency from the
government
in this case and not only is blm okay
with that
but if the blm accounts on social media
are any any indication they're downright
happy that the woman is dead
but what about those of us who have
integrity and who actually care about
things like truth and justice
you know we in that minority though of
course
those of us who care about truth and
justice we may never scream for justice
while we run out of a burned out foot
locker with an arm full of shoe boxes
but we still care about it
in fact it's because we care about you
rather justice that we wouldn't do that
those of us in that category what should
we think about this
well it's it's again it's hard to know
what to think because we're being told
so little about it
all we have is the video taken by
somebody in the crowd there is no doubt
all kinds of additional footage out
there security camera footage
body cam footage i mean it's it's a it's
a federal government building
and there's police officers all over the
place they no doubt have
tons of footage but we haven't seen any
of it
all we have is this and uh this is
disturbing of course because we're
watching a woman die but i think it's
important for us to watch it so because
this is all we have
to go on and let's watch it again now
take it down
so that's it um that that's all there is
to the
there are a couple other angles of the
shooting taken from
by by people in the crowd but that's you
know that's that's it
we can see that babbitt was unarmed and
climbing through a door
into a hallway with armed police
officers there were also we could also
see that there were heavily armed and
armored police officers coming up the
stairs behind her
she was literally surrounded on all
sides by armed police officers
one of the officers fired the shot again
the only officer on the scene that day
who apparently felt it necessary to take
that step
can we justify this shooting given the
circumstances
well if we can if we can the argument in
the unnamed cop's favor
would have to go something like this
ashley babbitt was trespassing with an
unruly mob in a government building
she was given multiple warnings to leave
the area the warnings may or may not
have been verbal but the hallway was
locked and barricaded and there were
police officers
guarding it with guns she knew she was
not supposed to keep going but she did
the officer
didn't know what her intentions were and
made the best decision he could in that
high pressure situation
that's what the argument in defense of
the shooting would sound like and i have
heard that exact argument
from many people including again the
same people who would in every other
situation
reject that same argument
personally i am not convinced by that
argument at all
i think it's extraordinarily weak
yes she was trespassing yes it was very
reckless to climb through that door
no i cannot defend that decision or tell
you what in the world
could have possibly been going through
her mind when she started to do that
but even so this is a five foot
two inch 110 pound middle-aged unarmed
woman
she was shot by a large male officer
are you telling me he couldn't have
easily taken her to the ground
easily through some other means
we know that she posed no physical risk
to him
whatsoever okay unless she's some sort
of
ninja or something she she posed no
physical risk to him we know that
can we really believe that he believed
that she did
she posed such a risk that he had to go
right to the gun shot
couldn't do anything else
and whatever he believed is it not
exceedingly clear that he could have
used
any number of non-lethal means to halt
her progress
progress here's another important
question
did he personally verbally warn her that
he was going to shoot
yeah there were all kinds of visual cues
that she wasn't supposed to climb
through the door
but did he actually yell to her and say
stop or i will shoot you if he did and
she kept coming then that might
change things in his favor certainly
makes him look a little better but if he
didn't
if he didn't say anything and simply
executed her on the spot
then this looks even more like a
straight-up murder of an unarmed citizen
and military veteran by a federal law
enforcement officer
now we could answer that question by the
way
about what the officer did or didn't say
if more footage was released or even if
they would just tell us
they know okay the department of justice
capitol police the politicians even the
media
i guarantee you all of them know who
that guy is and what exactly happened
they're not telling us
and the fact that they haven't told us
if he gave her a warning and said stop
or i'll shoot you
and she kept coming you'd think they'd
probably
tell us that the fact that they're not
telling us that and not telling us
anything else
that would seem to basically answer the
question no there was no warning
that's my guess and we're left only to
guess
my guess is very educated guess
reasonable guess there was no warning
from him verbally he just shot her
to my mind shooting an unarmed person
who poses no reasonable lethal threat to
you
without warning um
is murder now here's what we can say
though
if this shooting was justified
then a great many of the high-profile
shootings that blm has rioted over
were also justified any logically
consistent argument you can make that
would validate babbitt's killing
would also validate the killing of many
blm martyrs
all in one fell swoop that much we know
she was in the process of committing a
crime okay well so was george floyd so
that was michael brown
in the vast majority of these high
profile cases a crime was being
committed that's why the cops were there
she was given warnings well we don't
know if she was or not but we know that
jacob blake was
i mean he had guns pointed at him and
they were screaming at him over and over
again in his face
stop stop stop and he didn't stop until
they finally pulled the trigger
she was unarmed but could have still
theoretically posed a lethal threat well
blm has protested the killing of even
armed suspects like dion k in dc
was running towards officers with his
gun drawn
they protested that many others were not
armed but were still presenting
themselves as clear physical threats
like rayshard brooks in atlanta who got
into a fight with officers and stole one
of their tasers
she should have known better okay well
should dante wright not have known
better than to push away the officers
resist arrest and climb back into his
vehicle
if ashley babbitt brought her death on
herself
if she is to blame if she is not the
victim but the perpetrator who reaped
the consequences of her own actions
which seems to be the the opinion of
most people out there
certainly on the left but even a lot of
people on the right then the same
applies
to every name i just listed and then
some
oh but she was an insurrectionist trying
to take over a government building you
say
well if that's what makes the difference
if we're saying that what gives cops a
license to start spraying bullets
is that then that would put a great many
blm and antifa riders directly in the
line of fire
though in their case you know they've
been allowed to wage assaults on federal
buildings for months on end
sometimes even take over government
buildings at police stations and burn
them to the ground
without a single shot being fired at
them ever
but that brings us back to where we
started justice in two tiers
a system that favors some and not others
ashley babbitt falls on the losing side
of that coin
and no matter what they might say or
excuses they might offer in the minds of
blm
and the media and our government that is
why her death
is not an outrage or a crime
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content